Donald Trump is a divisive figure but
there is one thing everyone can agree on
nobody spins a new story harder than he
does the president was on top form this
week when the long-awaited Mueller
report on the Russian meddling in the
2016 US election and obstruction of
justice by the president finally landed
in Washington DC more specifically it
landed on the desk of Trump appointed
Attorney General William Bar the country
was desperately eager to see the results
but mr. bard immured he opted not to
share the three hundred page document
but instead offered his own four-page
summary
according to mr. Barr summary the report
cleared mr. Trump and his campaign of
collusion with Russia in the 2016
campaign and did not recommend charging
him with obstruction of justice although
it did not exonerate him either
that is when spin Meister Trump went
into full tornado mode the president
declared total exoneration and joyous
vindication while he danced and crowed
and triumph he also boiled in resentment
threatening retaliation against the
critics who backed the probe but the
investigation did expose a litany of
questionable interactions between mr.
Trump's allies and appointees with
Russian connections the report also
delves deeply and to Russia's efforts to
interfere in the u.s. election that
could be embarrassing for the president
when presented by his security services
with proof of Russian malfeasance in the
election mr. Trump has often given the
impression that he believes fled a mere
Putin's assertion of innocence
so any further revelations of juicy
details of Russian malice could set the
spin Meister's head spinning
[Music]